there are some reports getting
significant traction
that the department of justice is
deliberately waiting until after the
midterm election to indict donald trump
in order to not be seen
as making this political in order to
affect the midterms now a lot of common
sense applied to the circumstances
suggests that it's not likely trump
would be indicted before the midterms
anyway
and i'll tell you why in a moment couple
of different reports here
doj likely to wait past the midterms to
reveal any trump charges that's from
bloomberg's chris strome
federal prosecutors are likely to wait
until after the november election to
announce any charges against trump if
they determine that he broke laws
business insider reporting
if prosecutors decide to indict trump
they'll wait until after the november
midterms based on a report the move
would be in accordance with
long-standing policy that bars
prosecutors from taking overt steps that
could affect the outcome of an election
attorney general merrick garland also
recently introduced new restrictions to
quote maintain public trust in the doj
so there's a couple different things
that i think are important to mention
here first of all donald trump isn't on
any ballot so it's a
particular layer removed to if what is
happening here is the doj is saying
we're going to bring charges but not
until after the election
trump's not actually on any ballot
so it would be better to just do the job
that you're trying to do
um stop going so out of your way not to
be political because at the end of the
day when you're investigating current or
former elected officials you're not
going to avoid allegations that it is
political in some sense now if donald
trump were on the ballot if donald trump
were running for something in november
and two weeks before he is charged with
a crime although
it still could be completely correct and
apolitical we've gotten all the evidence
we've gotten all the uh as sean hannity
calls it the eyes
crossed and the t's dotted and we're
ready to go if that's the timing to
deliberately wait until after the
election that actually seems more
politically motivated than just charging
when you're ready to charge but that's
not the case here because trump's not
even on the ballot so if this were the
calculation that were being made by the
doj
it is a very indirect thing where it's
well even though trump's not on the
ballot
there are members of his party on the
ballot and people that he has endorsed
on the ballot so let's wait i would be
completely against that but i actually
think that this entire narrative may not
be accurate
and the reason i say that
is it does take a while to put together
charges and according to people
familiar with what's going on
eight and a half weeks for charges they
just got a huge chunk of documents uh
it's now september in in august weeks
ago
it is often the case that it takes
months after search warrants are served
to finalize what are all the charges now
without a doubt when the fbi decides
we're going into the home of a former
president which they they don't often
decide arguably this is the first time
it's happened
you'd better damn well be sure
that they already know
likely charges that are on the other end
of this
and they know exactly what they're
looking for and what they believe took
place
but at the same time
you've got to go through every document
you have to see the legal implications
of every document that's there later i'm
going to tell you about multiple trump
associates who believe there are more
documents or there are copies of
documents that donald trump still has
stashed elsewhere and so
it's not particularly realistic to think
that within 10 weeks of getting the
documents to begin with you're already
going to be charging donald trump so
while i completely disagree with the
idea of deliberately waiting to file
charges until after the election because
trump's not even on the ballot i totally
disagree with that if that is what is
going on
it seems more likely to me
that the timeline is going to extend
beyond the first week of november anyway
and um i do believe we will see an
indictment but i think it's going to
come later now when we see the
indictment it will be very interesting
to see how trump's lawyers react and we
have a little bit of a preview of that
the david pakman show's longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time
but there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at
blinkist.com david pakman the link is
down below